if we can step into the Practical we're
talking about historical and
philosophical into the Practical of
today
what are some of the exciting policies
that represent Democratic socialism
today modern socialism
uh I think you mentioned some of them
you know Medicare for all or Universal
Health Care
something you haven't mentioned is
tuition-free college
increasing minimum wage maybe stronger
unions like we talked about
what are some ideas here what are some
ideas there's especially policies
especially exciting to you
well I think that hours reduction has
always been an important demand for
socialists
um so I mean it's been a reality in in
certain countries like France and in
recent uh decades
where part of the logic is
if you have a bunch of people working
for 40 plus hours a week and you also
have some unemployed people who would
like more employment then it's not a
zero-sum game you could reduce hours to
35 hours and still maintain the same
output by employing more people to kind
of fill the the slack in in hours so one
I think it's a solidaristic thing in
working class movements being unemployed
and employed workers I also think that
um yeah it gives people more time so
Marx was a big advocate in his day of um
a 10-hour
um a bill in in in the UK that would
reduce the hours of working time
and reduce child or eliminated or renews
child labor and and other things as well
and part of it was
this is a radical demand because it's
reducing the sphere as we saw of
exploitation so it's putting limits on
on how much time the capitalist can take
from ordinary workers and how much
Freedom they would they would have
um with Healthcare one I just think it's
a a government Health Care System you
know you could tell me that you don't
want it in the U.S but you can't tell me
it doesn't work because we've seen it
work in every other major industrial
system in different forms so what does
that usually involve what does Universal
Health Care involve so there's different
varieties in the UK for instance they
have a National Health Service in which
medical personnels and hospitals are run
directly by the state it's almost like a
mini Soviet system to be honest but just
for health care and it works pretty well
just for healthcare
um and I think it's one example of the
way in which you could actually take the
market so I give you a vision of
socialism that involves a lot of Market
but I think there's certain spheres
where you could remove the market from
and still have
um an efficient system
um in part because you know this is a
area in which we
people don't have
obviously for cosmetic procedures
whatever they have preferences but for
most routine things that people do in
healthcare they just need to see a
doctor you know they need to get
diagnosed
um some of these systems have had
trouble with waitlist for Specialists or
whatever that's more of like an
allocation problem of if you want more
Specialists you pay Specialists more
like this is just problems that could be
solved by like through the mechanisms of
of planning and and government-run
Healthcare so that's that's kind of the
most left-wing that you could get is
what the system the United Kingdom
um
beyond that you have a system like
Medicare for all where you say all right
most of the doctors besides for public
hospitals that already exist
um are going to be privately employed by
Hospitals now hospitals are going to be
private
but
um instead of having all these different
insurance carriers we're just gonna have
one national insurance carrier that
we're all going to pay into that
national insurance carrier is going to
negotiate
um the price of Health Care with doctors
the price of
um of drugs with pharmaceutical
companies and so on to hopefully reduce
um uh prices and to implement a
different little bit of planning into
into the system because if there's only
one you know big National Insurance
Company
um that that company has a lot of weight
and power but you know you could still
visit your same doctor and
um there's still some uh it's not as
radical of a of a shift in that
direction and that's a dominant demand
of Bernie Sanders and the left right now
there's 30 plus million people in the
U.S would be insured that currently
aren't insured if we move to the system
there's a lot of other people that are
underinsured or worried about how to pay
co-pays or or premiums involved I think
would be a net benefit for the vast
majority of the US
um population even if it was offset with
certain taxes because we spend a lot of
money out of pocket with with health
insurance and it's the demand also
that's like widely popular so for me
it's almost like if you're trying to
build support for
um something like socialism we were
talking this Loft division of socialism
after capitalism or what worker
um ownership the means of production
would look like in practice and and so
on and by the way you're one of the few
interviewers who ever asked me any of
the the details so it's good that I had
a I've been thinking of a rough sketch
in my head for the last you know
um whatever 16 years I've been a
socialist
but
but we have to start in the here and now
and if you can't convince people that
the state should play a bigger role in
their health insurance and you can't
convince Americans and a whole host of
other sectors that they should be living
in something closer to social democracy
how are you going to convince those
people that there should be worker
ownership of the means of production
yeah it's kind of a ridiculous like leap
um if if you don't have the credibility
as the group of people organizing for
universal healthcare organizing for a 15
minimum wage and able to get the goods
and also in practice as we fight for
these reforms
ordinary people will have a better sense
at least my hope is of what it means to
be involved with politics and what
politics can do for their lives it's
positive because right now when we talk
about politics it often just seems that
we're talking about
um like a very glib cultural conflict
removed from the things that are
important in our lives whereas in truth
I think politics can be a tool for us to
make our lives better
yeah and there's like deep ideas here
where in some sense Universal Health
Care and worker collectives are not so
radically different that there is just
uh there's philosophical ideas to
explore and accept and also from my
perspective at least
maybe I'm wrong on this but it seems
like with a lot of things
at the core of Politics the right answer
from an alien perspective is not clear
like everybody's very certain of what's
the right answer everyone's certain
Universal Health Care is terrible or in
the case of Universal Health Care
majority of people think it's a good
idea but I don't think anyone knows
because I think that depends on cultural
history on the on the particular
dynamics of a country of a political
system on the Dynamics of the economic
system in this country of the changing
world the 21st century is different than
the 20th century maybe the failures of
Communism in the 20th century will not
be repeated in the 21st century or the
flip side of that may be capitalism will
actually truly flourish
are with the help of Automation in the
21st century like I don't think anyone
knows so like you people like you are
basically saying like arguing for ideas
and we'll have to explore those ideas
together
um
why do you think if Universal Health
Care is popular
why don't we have Universal Health Care
in the United States well
democracy is a great thing political
democracy is wonderful it came from the
struggles of ordinary people to expand
suffrage and and so on but the economic
sphere entrenched power in the economic
sphere bleeds into our political
democracy so I think there's a lot of
people with a vested interest in not
having Universal Health Care
um there's large Industries with the
best interest in not having Universal
Health Care
they pay for ads pay lobbyists they
influence government and they have made
it very difficult so you can't get
Universal Health Care
um done without the bill even if you
pass something you're trying to make a
change like Obamacare was supposed to
have a public option everybody's been
running on a public option in the
Democratic party for 12 13 years why
don't we have a public option
um people know that if people have the
choice of buying into a government plan
they might just keep that might be the
slow road to really having Universal
Health Care so I think a lot of it's
opposition
do you like that idea the public option
maybe you can like because is there
complexities like pre-existing
conditions
so isn't a public option
mean you can not have any insurance
until you get into trouble
and then you can if it covers
pre-existing conditions just start
paying for insurance then therefore
young people don't pay for insurance
isn't it better to go full in I don't
support a public option in part because
I think if we allow politicians to just
say hey I support a public option well
it's just kind of a way to Signal your
support for Universal Health Care would
give us nothing and I think that's what
we saw under with Biden a lot of other
politicians that have supported uh
public option I think in practice if a
public option is defined in such a way
that it just means
you you
um you know by default can just opt in
to a public plan and let's say
hypothetically you don't even have to
pay for it then it's just a back door to
universal healthcare really quickly
because I think the vast majority of
people who aren't currently covered and
also a lot of employers to be honest
would probably drop their private
coverage if they knew their employees
can just get a public option and maybe
would only provide supplemental
insurance or or whatever else
um but I think the broad overarching
point of all these demands is to say
that
socialists need to be really connected
to the day-to-day struggles of people to
just improve their lives
so if you're feeling like you're paying
400 500 on the Obamacare market for
health insurance and that's hampering
your ability to do what you want to do
in your life then maybe you would
support a candidate who's for Universal
Health Care if you feel like you're
struggling to find work that you could
afford to pay your rent with or whatever
else maybe it'll support a candidate
committed to
um all sorts of mechanisms to reduce
housing prices or increase your power as
a as a tenant
um and you know whatever else I think
it's like these day-to-day concerns need
to be connected to the more abstract and
lofty vision of change otherwise our
politics just becomes like this this
fantasy world thing that's that's you
know nice ideas to think about or debate
but but really won't make much of a
difference in people's lives
what do you think about free college
should College be free
so I would say free college is not at
the top of my list of priorities but it
definitely should be for you in my
vision of a just
um just Society what is it that you tell
just to clarify is the Universal Health
Care up there yeah universal healthcare
is probably far higher in my priorities
than than free college I think right now
the way our system is built
when someone goes to college they're
given credentials they're given decree
they carry with them for the rest of
their life it gives them a chance to
join kind of a privileged part of the
labor market right it's not a zero-sum
game I don't want college-educated
people to think that non-college
educated people are their enemies and
vice versa because a lot of them are
just ordinary Working Class People
trying to survive
and they're in different areas they're
in different sectors
um you know some of them are in nursing
sectors where they need a college degree
and and so on
but if you just make College tuition
free but you don't also make uh trades
skills and other things
um tuition free for someone to learn how
to become an electrician or a plumber or
whatever else then to some degree you're
privileging one sector of the labor
market over another
um so I would Advocate just if you're
going to make something like that free
you just have to make sure that you're
doing an egalitarian way and that one
the options the routes to college are
more more equal so
um you know there's more investment in
K-12 education so that more kids in
rough neighborhoods have the chance to
go to college and for those that choose
the trade route from from any any part
of the country that they're given the
skills and resources for vocational
um you know trainings and that those are
also free and it just feels like in
terms of order of operation I would just
start with K-12 education improving it
and and whatever else then
College after but I'm not opposed to it
so does that improving K-12 education
does that mean investing more into it is
it as simple as just increasing the
amount of money that's invested in the
in public education in general when it
comes to the public sector or any any
sphere that you're investing in uh
obviously it's not just as simple as
throwing money at a problem I do think
we have a lot of schools that are
um underfunded but we have other schools
that are adequately funded but the
conditions in which those schools are
like the neighborhoods they're in and
what's going on in society
um the problems are so deep that it's
impossible for just education to solve
everything and I think especially a lot
of liberals think that education should
be the Panacea invest in education
you'll help people if kids are living in
poverty if they go into school hungry or
whatever else like education's not gonna
give them
everything they need to to succeed so
sometimes we I think put too much weight
on on education
and of course you can Define education
more broadly which is like
the care
of the flourishing of the young mind
whatever that is yeah whatever you call
this earlier yeah a lot of it starts
with so New York City at least we do
have
um Universal Pre-K so from H3 onward you
you have the option for that I mean it's
important for kids socialization you
know their parents are now able to you
know know that they could go to work or
do something else and have their you
know have their kids taken care of
um there's a lot of measures like that
that we could do to to equalize things
and again
for Libertarians in the audience you
know some of this stuff is scary because
it's obviously more State involved State
involved in pre-K
State it's already very involved in K-12
more investment into State institutions
like um our our state universities and
in college but for me it's not a
question of State versus non-state it's
a question of
um you know good outcomes for for people
and it just happens to be that for
Working Class People
um
having the collective power to elect
representatives that will build a
broader safety net is in their interest
for upper middle class people for others
they can afford to pay for their own
provisioning either directly or through
like Obamacare like schemes where you
just get a subsidy and you pay the rest
yourself and whatever this is for really
the bottom 40 plus of the population
they really don't have any options so
they prioritize others things they end
up with with some sort of injury or
health problem or whatever else and it's
it's bad for everyone in society but
especially bad for the people at the
bottom of the the labor market so I saw
various estimates for socialist programs
like Social Security expansion free
college
uh Medicare for all will cost upwards of
40 trillion dollars over 10 years for
zero okay to give argue with those
numbers and so on but so there's a cost
there's a taxpayer cost what are
given the weight of that cost
uh can you still make the case with
these programs and then can you try to
make the case against them that the cost
is too high so I I will
not argue with you on the numbers
because you're just threat random
numbers I do think Universal Health Care
if Done Right can be basically cost
neutral I think it's an exception
because we spend a tremendous amount of
money on on Health Care a huge
percentage of our GDP so I think it
could be done in a way that's close to
um class neutral so let's see can you
argue on the numbers without arguing on
the numbers you're saying just your gut
says that there's a lot of depending on
how these programs are done there's a
lot of variants in how much it will
actually cost there's a lot of
bureaucracy in Billing right now in our
Healthcare sector for example that would
be
um eliminated
um there's a lot of costs that are
spiraling upward of Provider costs from
both Doctors Hospitals but also
Pharmaceuticals to drug costs that
insurance companies shoulder because the
their market share is too fragmented to
really negotiate hard
um Medicare could sometimes negotiate
better rates but a Medicare for all
would negotiate even better rates so I
think there's a cost spiral that we can
adjust with more government
um involvement and there's a reason why
we spend a bigger share of our GDP on
health care than other places but but
let me just accept the broad premise
that social programs cost money
um
now
I think that that one for ordinary
people most of them
the trade-off of even hypothetically if
if taxes on
um lower middle class and working less
people in certain cases go up
the trade-off would still be in their
benefit because they're the ones who
currently who would be consuming more of
those goods and also our tax system and
whatnot is Progressive so the the rich
will pay pay more
the majority will consume
um more of them
um also I think a lot of these programs
are the Bedrock of a healthy Society
so one reason for example that we have
um so much crime and violence in the US
there's lots of you know cultural and
other causes with our level of gun
ownership American history and and so on
but one one really important factor is
just the level of poverty and inequality
in the US compared to other other
countries that combined with guns and
and other factors I mean so we live in
more violent unequal societies if you
know a European would be shocked by the
fact that in even some of our our nicest
areas and our and cities and elsewhere
because there's a lot of rural violence
too it's just normal to have gun uh
violence it's normal to have drug
related violence you know the we have
what like four or 500 people some years
in like Baltimore like a city of under a
million getting getting killed um
these are all recipes for society in
which one the public sphere is is drunk
like crazy because you're not gonna go
wander out for an evening stroll in a
park if you live in a dangerous area or
whatever else like the the rot goes very
deep and a welfare state is one way to
to live in a better Society for everyone
um there's been plenty of of studies uh
there's one book called the spirit level
on um on inequality that was quite
popular that just notes that inequality
is really terrible for the psyches
um of the rich too not just for for the
poor so I think uh spending some more
money living in more just Society is is
doable there's different ways to to
address certain costs
um spirals one reason why our welfare
states are getting more and more
expensive is in part just because our
population is is aging but many of the
same people who say we can't afford
um more in our welfare states because
um you know we're already spending so
much on Social Security and all these
other entitlements are the same people
also for one you know closing borders so
immigrants can't come in uh to to help
build the economy and to fill gaps in
the economy and also who aren't for
things that'll make it easier to have
kids you know I'm 33 years old I have a
lot of friends
um who have been putting them off having
kids until they save up x amount of
dollars even though they have someone
they could you know uh raise raise
children with
um because they can't afford the cost of
child care they can't they can't you
know their job probably won't give them
more than four or six weeks of of um
family leave or whatever else like this
is not the case in other other countries
so I think there's all sorts of benefits
from having a bigger uh welfare state
but yes there are costs and there are
going to be certain trade-offs it's not
a magical thing where you could just you
know have everything without trade-offs
so in a progressive Tech system
is there
to to push back on the cost here
is there a point at which taxing the
rich
uh is counterproductive in the long term
so in the short term there might be a
net benefit of increasing taxes
um because the programs the middle class
the lower middle class gets is more
beneficial
is there is there a negative side to
taxing the rich
in theory yes of course a one would be
um if you tax the bridge so much
they change their consumption patterns
and that has negative impacts in the
economy as a whole that you like you
would have to kind of really model it
out but there would be a certain point
in which the consumption changes might
have net detrimental effects
um I think that's more unlikely and the
more likely scenario is you can tax
corporations and and other
um uh wealthy you know people in society
to the point that
um they have potentially less money for
productive investment because you're in
a capital Society so you're relying on
capitalists to invest
so you kind of don't want to be in the
worst of Both Worlds where you've gone
too far for capitalism but not far
enough for socialism
um and my vision of course of socialism
that's one reason why we'd have to take
the investment function away from
kaplers there has to be if you're gonna
make it so hard for them that they can't
invest or they can't employ labor the
way they're employing now you have to
create another mechanism for Supply to
be created and that's why that's a
transition Point yeah
um what about longer term
de-incentivizing young people that are
dreaming of becoming entrepreneurs and
realizing that there's this huge tax on
being wealthy so if you take these big
risks which is what's required to be an
entrepreneur
and you are lucky enough to succeed and
good enough to succeed that the
government will take most of your money
away
I think realistically that's not a
disincentive for most people
um first of all we already have
progressive taxation system uh the
government does take take a bunch of the
money away and people are still striving
to become rich a lot of what people want
when they dream of success is they want
accolades they want respect and of
course they want
some more wealth well to consume luxury
goods with or whatever else but at a
certain point it becomes better for the
state to
um to tax and either redistribute
directly or through social programs or
redirect that money through tax credits
and on other ways to shape investment
towards productive investment you know
we don't want a society in which a bunch
of rich people fly around a helicopters
going from klepto Club while the
productive economy
um kind of does nothing right at that
point I think a lot of ordinary rich
people might prefer
the government to come in to tax them
and to try to Spur investment in certain
productive
um sectors so it really just just
depends but I honestly believe that that
most people
don't necessarily want to be rich for
the sake of being rich they want to be
successful and there's many different
Dynamics to that and accolades and
social respect is is an important one of
them it's also why people who just
become Filthy Rich often the first thing
they do is start out philanthropic trust
and try to give away their money because
they want the social respect and
accolades and whatever else they don't
want just their money